so they can can you honestly say that if
kane is
just obviously hypothetically if kane
scored the winning goal to win england
the euros of the world cup you are not
celebrating i would have said right now
that is mental yeah
okay the question is the invincibles
are overrated three two
look all i'm hearing is going on and on
about being i'll be in when let's be
honest like almost half the games
withdrawals
you're well lack of success in europe
that year as well i think chelsea the
next is the next year i think chelsea
the next season
miles better than the invincibles yeah
they lost one game
but they the amount of points that they
got
invincible the united united to the
treble
even man city centurions is better than
the than the invincibles well you'd be
next to saying that the oldie cups
better on it
but the top than one night i mean 100
points right
more points the more goals like yeah but
unbeaten
i do agree with slightly agree with you
that are that that
invincible team should have won more it
should have gone on and won the european
cup
uh which it didn't or the champions
league he should have gone and done that
and it didn't because we um again arsene
wenger
um playing weekend teams in semi-finals
of fa cups and then the moment we lost a
little bit momentum to that
but ultimately this moment in time
people go and yeah
it's not great which you just said
they're agreeing all that like well if
it's that simple
why has no other team ever done it no
one's saying it's not
it's a great achievement or a good
achievement well the question was
overrated
overrated it would be overrated because
everyone's banging on about being
the best team ever in the premier league
era so can you because you're in
disagreement
i'm not saying we were the best team
ever because we did that that was just a
great send off for a stadium
that's all it was but then we weren't
banging on about it we were the best
yeah
i've seen countless i've heard countless
other people saying that it's the best
it's the best team getting invincible no
one's ever done the best team ever so i
don't unders
i think you're right i'm strongly
disagreeing with that okay
honestly like you know what you're
saying you know
listen this conversation with a spurs
fan about unbeaten seasons you know what
i
mean
you know
for the whole of the season it's
something that's unbelievable
achievement
um and you know what i ain't i ain't
afraid to say it i'm proud of that proud
of
being a part of that history uh a gold
trophy doesn't mean it's not over
though i don't think it's overrated if
you can go
unbeaten at the end of and like you know
you've always got the
the bitter fans that turn around and say
like oh you've got a couple of drawers
in that like you know so what you don't
mean like the end of the day unbeaten
you've got to go through the whole
season unbeaten
and ultimately if it was that easy
we've managed to see with all the money
and all the power they've got
and the best manager that's ever come
but it's best manager by the way since
sliced bread
all right all of a sudden he's still not
done it yeah but he's one
arsenal countless more trophies with
with him yeah but he hasn't got that
gold one is he you know
one of the best teams to watch i didn't
say you weren't one of why the reason
i'm saying this over racism
is because everyone's saying you are the
best team in the premier league era
which i just
completely disagree with hence why i'm
saying it's overrated
well if you're unbeaten
someone else try and match it no one is
saul campbell
needed the correct decision
correct decision the thing is i when i
know you're straight away you're gonna
go in yeah it was the right move because
he's one trophy
i'm just talking about the manner that
everything was done in like
the right i'm going to be the right
decision with the waves said he's not
leaving
right absolutely
they turned down 15 million from man
united the year before and he turned
around and said
no i i don't i don't want to move um i'm
happy at tottenham and
then he turned up the arsenal i'll never
forget like you know the day that he
said
do you know what it was it was a
fantastic day that he signed because it
it it really yeah i will be nasty as
first it
sent out a message not only that um
the arsenal were a bigger club it just
sent out it just
hurt tottenham fans so so well like you
know what i mean
and they're still sucking on lemons to
this day they're still sucking up
because they're so good
because i'm grateful that i was in
diapers at the time that happened
because
at least i didn't have to go through
that but i just anything to do so i
can't go in any sort of
agreement with that there's there's too
much hurt in there i just feel like it
was the total wrong way
to go by at all moving obviously of
course you're gonna love it yeah
because he won trophies as well you know
what he didn't he
he actually said on the day that he
signed i'm going to arsenal to win
trophies
and he did you know what i mean so
strongly agree like you know now from
from a spurs point of view it's not
great that what he done free transfer
and everything like that
and i get why spurs fans will never
never
take to him or whatever you know um i
get that
but but i wouldn't really it's just not
it's a lovely snake
that's perfect that's weird
harry kane is a better all-around
striker
than thierry henry ever was three
two one
that's killer listen i i think harry
kane i'll be honest i think harry kane
is a very very good striker
very very good striker can do most
things
in a premier league but tyrion were just
dead you know i mean probably like
ultimately one of the best players i've
ever seen play football
whatever it may be i think in terms of
just playing ability and what he offers
on the pitch
i just feel like kane edges it just a
bit for me if we're talking that aspect
especially because he's only
about 10 goals behind him in the
previous top score list and he's still
got
easily like five years left in him in
the premier league easily
yeah i like listen i think he's a great
goal scorer i've got to say that i don't
you know i think that the spurs biasing
this has come in here
i've got i've got a right now you know i
mean i i i think um
even the most deluded spurs fans would
probably say at this moment in time
that omri is the better player you know
sanogo's got more medals than harry's
name at this moment in time
if i'll be honest there's a line uh
harry kane's on that line
and tyrion is just above it okay
is it truly that you don't celebrate
when harry kane scores britain
oh i saw those two that was ridiculous
no i don't know
no i don't i don't want to leave it i'll
tell you what i'm right
right all right can't believe why is it
because i would go
mental if sakura scored the winning goal
what about show campbell scored
but kane didn't leave him
ah almost said excuse me but now it's
club over the country
yeah i mean but and then i go one player
you
is pretty much any other first man
celebrating
this first fans have a government i'd
say i'm not all supposed to because i've
got
a couple of mates alright and then they
turn around one of my spurs mate says
like
you're all right because i never i will
ever
celebrate when sol campbell scored
against uh i can't remember his school
about sweden in
2002 he said i would never never
celebrate that
but it's club versus country that's
totally different now it's not his club
right
club
because the way he left us as a captain
and said he wasn't going to leave
nothing to do with england it's got
nothing to do with england yeah because
i don't
like the academics at the end of the day
you know but now it but this is what i'm
saying because that was such a
disgraceful i'm not going to settle in
whereas why i'm being funny versus
country i i don't celebrate harry kane
england is totally different to the club
that's exactly what all the
all the players the reason we're doing
better as a country
competition specifically talking about
won't if if another if
whoever if someone other arsenal player
scored the winner i would celebrate it
because it's about england not arsenal
spurs well that is a very specific
annoying argument with seoul campbell
though
the spurs fan brought it out for me you
know and that's my argument
he actually said that to me i don't
celebrate harry kane girls because for
the five years and it's a compliment to
him really
he's made my life hell so they can can
you honestly say that if kane
is just obviously hypothetically if kane
scored the
winning goal to win england the euros of
the world cup you are not celebrating i
would have said right now
that's mental yeah that is mental spurs
did not deserve their invitation to the
super league
three two one i'll let you have a drink
first
um oh come on come on
now you know what i've got an argument
you've got an
super league all about money i was
against the whole thing so
i don't even care though but yeah i'm
just happy it's over the super league
the whole thing
was just about money and making money in
sports
tottenham were like i think at the time
seventh highest revenue in europe
and in the top 10 richest clubs that's
why we were invited
not necessarily because of the success
because you could argue that ourselves
of recent success has been
pretty much non-existent if we're
talking about top many of mine these are
supposed to be
obviously the top teams in europe you
can't say arsenal are one of those
either
no so it's purely purely money based in
my opinion americans trying to come over
and just franchise the whole thing
so i think i don't want to say deserved
because i don't want things happen in
the first place but
deserve the place because it's all about
the money and the revenue that we're
making
and obviously the stadium and all that
sort of stuff as soon as you mention the
word super
that is it for me like spurs are not in
it right you know yeah the league itself
isn't exactly
but i'm going to be let's be honest i'll
be really honest
i don't think arsenal should have been
in it really that's the truth but
you know then you know he's laughing no
wonder he got thrown out like you know
when they put spurs in it like you know
because it is except the same about you
that it might say this well come on not
you know what i mean they've not both of
us to be invited the last time she's
been possible really
at least i asked more of the
championship or title
in color you know what i mean like there
was videos out and alright but
by that point black and white head of
arsenal well i know
you have to look at it let's be this be
serious here i'll tell you what
i have all those teams right i'll give
you a cl i'll give you a question right
only one team has never won the title
for 30 odd years or 40 years
in that can you know who that team was
today
to be honest with you funny like you
know the only team that hasn't won a
trophy in the last
50 years in that super league
was uh was that i even had aston villa
fans having the moment of me saying like
you know if tottenham are in it
then we should be in it no space fans
saying that they should be because
they've won the european cup you know
it made it a fast come on you've noticed
[Music]
i'm going off the question was did we
deserve the place in the super league
i'm telling what the super league for
what it was
that's the reason why we got invited
hence why i'm well because you've got a
picture i agree with you but i agree i
actually agree with you in the sense
that in terms of like what we want or
whatever
it didn't make any sense but the super
league was a
cash cow money machine and at the moment
we're making
the most money what some of the highest
most money in europe
so of course we were going to get the
invite to that for that reason hence why
i'm there
i don't want okay it should be like then
but like i'm not going to go into the
in in into that so i
uh
anyway it's been a pleasure yeah cheers
see you in the 7th
and so what we're going to have a three
hour long football game because we're
going to check every decision for two or
three minutes there's no one's
suggesting that are they well
you're suggesting that we need to get
every decision right no i'm not
suggesting that well
i did not cycle you're saying that it's
really important that we get everything
right like they do in the hundred meter
final and we don't want to ruin the
experience
everything how many things are we going
to get right the important things the
biggest thing to find important
like you know red cards penalties things
like that